for seven decades we've been celebrating
with her
the music the fashions and those on the
balcony constantly changing yet always
at the center of it one woman as the
first british monarch to ever mark a
platinum jubilee it's inevitable that
the world and the country will be
watching her but also the rest of her
family because after what has been a
difficult time for the royals this will
in some ways be a test of how britain is
really feeling about the monarchy
this was 1952. in the new town of
hammerhamsted had plenty of progress to
show the queen
her majesty was welcomed with a bouquet
and little lorna humphries certainly
proved she'd mastered the art of the
curtsy on one of her first visits as
queen dressed for the weather rather
than for royalty young susan applegate
watched the queen leave the home of the
adams family
on the same estate now the jubilee pub
in queen square has just reopened some
of their grandparents lived here when
the queen came if she turned up today or
if another member of the royal family
turned up today yeah what kind of
reaction do you think they'd get
she'd be hurry i don't know about the
rest it's good for the country
considering what we've had to put up
with over the last few years i think we
should all be out celebrating and making
a big big deal out of it really which is
magic but
it's just not the well-known magic
element here francis is the new landlord
a lot of people that are just thinking
it's two days extra off work
if i was to ask a lot of young people
they wouldn't care one way or the other
it's always the older generation now
that will because i say we've grown up
knowing her from when she was young
self-employment you lose two days money
and that's gotta hurt a lot of families
of course the past 70 years have had
their challenges the silver jubilee in
1977 a time of enormous social change
the golden jubilee in 2002 coming after
a difficult decade of family dramas
and 2012's diamond jubilee happier times
[Applause]
but also a backdrop of riots and unrest
she has moderated and adapted to
changing times the metoo movement black
lives matter now these impact on us all
not just externally in in the news forum
but often personally our lives come up
against these different ways of
interacting and being with each other
likewise the queen's very own family
recently her family have again caused
the most difficulties and it does appear
to have affected recent polling with 41
of 18 to 24 year olds now saying that
britain should have an elected head of
state
lord lieutenant for bristol peaches
golding still believes the royals are
winning people over with their work
these are the things that pull us
together as a country themes from
environment to mental health
there is
i think great stability and a
constitutional monarchy and her majesty
has proven that time and time again
this year the queen has decided only
working royals will appear on the
balcony a chance to show us she believes
the monarchy is in safe hands as she
celebrates a milestone like no other
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace